[Musique]
bon aujourd'hui on est pas mal je vous
emmène à amsterdam on est venu voir des
nouveautés de philips pour parler de tv
alors c'est vrai que je vous en parle
assez peu mais il ya toujours plein de
belles histoires racontées au niveau de
la télé au niveau du son plein de
surprises je ne sais pas exactement tout
ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui je pense
que ma réponse ça se passe sur deux
jours on arrive aujourd'hui à amsterdam
on est le mardi il ya aussi le mercredi
et je pense à mon avis on va bien se
marrer
alors je dormais avec mon escapade
lumière ce serait un petit peu mieux
notés les officines vous allez voir le
truc est extrêmement rare
[Musique]
et qui file juste à côté de l'aéroport à
l'instar de là il ya quoi combien
d'étoilés moi tu dirais si quelque chose
comme 25 étages moi je suis au cinquième
plutôt bien pour la plupart comptent
vraiment les détails comment les étals
j'ai pas vous en faire des heures sur
l'automne mais c'est vrai que ça s'est
quand même hyper hyper impressionnant
bon on est quand même plutôt pas mal
loti plutôt pas mal logés ça c'est bien
mais c'est pas le plus important
non parce qu'aujourd'hui le plus
important c'est effectivement de vous
parler de félipe c'est la nouveauté et
niveau telle est la nouveauté niveau
audio on en parle sur deux jours vous
aller voir mon avis on est plutôt pas
mal
[Musique]
ibm et apple ou google
alors laissez moi vous expliquer il ya
des nouveautés chez philips alors
philips ya plein de parties différentes
plein catégories différentes ici on a
deux points réellement différent
convient traite aujourd'hui la partie
télé moi mais de ce côté-là et la partie
audio qu'on va mettre de ce côté là on a
des nouveautés télé de l'oled plein
chose ça je vous en reparle dans
quelques instants il y en à la partie
audio avec un nouveau casque casque
fidelio x3 un casque qu'on va brancher
ici écrite avec des jack de chaque côté
sur parle pas de casque bluetooth ici a
pas de connexion sans fil ici un fils un
gros film under branché pour garder le
maximum de qualité c'est la dance et
l'idée de ce produit c'est un casque
ouvert ce qu'on va faire le plus simple
c'est que pour la partie télé eh bien on
va aller en parler directement de
delphine et on va les voir benoît pour
la partie audio
[Musique]
je me fais à cause de dieu lumière mais
les magnifiques pp genre ya des gens qui
voient la vierge
tu l'as vu en 3d aux couleurs
[Musique]
oui bon est ce que tu peux te présenter
pour ceux qui ne te connaissent pas ou
qui ne connaîtraient pas bonjour je suis
delphine guinée je suis directrice
marketing chez télévision comme ça ça
c'est fait s'est posé ses cadres ok
plein de nouveautés oui aujourd'hui du
côté de chez philips télévision c'est la
partie vidéo party wii audio également
exactement mal baptiste humel du cjd
teese la partie télé de mardi le bouchon
trop loin dans son équipe et on se lance
et compte et ne bouge pas c'est super il
vaut mieux que je te parle
oh que je lui parle à moi tu parles là
mais tu ne regarde pas ça oui oui là tu
vas regarde donc télévision
effectivement c'est la marque philips
pour les réviseurs tout ce qui est audio
quand on dit adios et les barres de son
les casques ledoux traditionnelle au
lieu chez ni filet
ce sont là beaucoup de produire ses
angles boucle produits bon alors oulémas
pourquoi aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui
on est là pour se parler des gammes 2020
voilà on sait d'ici quelques mois que ce
soit en écran les téléviseurs mais
également le module wii pour la partie
écran quelles sont les nouveautés cette
année j'étais alors chez philips et
cette année on a deux
deux nouveautés dans les téléviseurs
oled et on a des téléviseurs
lv qu'on appelle the one qui est un
concept vraiment coeur de gamme qui
rassemble tout ce qu'on peut demander à
un écran qui soit quatre cas qu'ils
soient connectés qui soit android qui
est une très bonne qualité d'image une
bonne qualité de son avec du contenu
donc et surtout qu'il est l'ambilight
parce qu'en 2020 tous les téléphones
mobiles ait oui c'est pas faux c'est pas
faux c'est hyper grâce à un petit
éditeur ans pourront au delà de vous
toutes les télés en bilingue du monde
qui est vrai mais particulièrement
s'intéresse aux télévisions le mec elbaz
a comme ça directement intégrés
ambilight dans nos télés être plus
prononcé va geler les intéressait
vraiment super cerexhe atteint vraiment
d'ouvrir et d'élargir complètement les
horizons vraiment et puis une immersion
dans l'image
génial expérience dans l'assaut matters
est alors l'idée de the one c'est quoi
ça s'adresse à quel public
elle est aujourd'hui ça s'adresse au
grand public un public très philips qui
est familiale qui veut un écran ou à
renouveler l'achat d'un téléviseur et on
va de 43 pouces jusqu'à 70 pouces voilà
vraiment toutes les tailles d'écran on
veut un téléviseur qui a une bonne
qualité d'image donc une dalle 4k
évidemment un bon processeur qui nous
fournit la qualité d'image un bon son je
le disais tout à l'heure une
connectivité on a une plateforme android
dont qui me permet d'avoir vraiment
beaucoup de contenu la nouveauté de
cette année c'est l'intégration de
l'application disney plus soul et là
notamment avec ses démonstrations star
wars extrêmement bien sérieux ça tu me
de l'ambilight derrière c'est magnifique
c'est une grosse valeur jouit à
exactement ça c'est vrai que c'est hyper
différenciant par rapport à ce qu'on
trouve sur le reste du marché exactement
vous trouvez que chez philips depuis
toujours qu'on a toujours parlé dans be
live aujourd'hui nos clients adorent
l'ambilight 80 % de nos clients qui ont
un mobile ait retour en acheter un
on a une vraie fidélité sur cette
caractéristique est les unit c'est une
des décisions d'achat vraiment j'irai
plus important quand les gens veulent
acheter un téléviseur celles ci viennent
pourquoi ils viennent pour l'ambiance le
premier alors y en a beaucoup qui
viennent pour l'ambiance
j'ai la vie on est les seuls à fournir
donc ils veulent renouveler leur télé
x10 bon ben si je veux l'ambilight il
faut que je prenne philippe orgueil très
bien et après évidemment que la qualité
d'image reste un point
il perd sur the one hand situe donc
qu'elle tarification à peu près on peut
se dire que pour 1 55 pouces on est
autour d'un millier d'euros 10 mois par
rapport au relais de maintenant vous
avec de nouvelles références au
catalogue ouled sidi pas de bêtises 7 la
wii alors on a desserré 8 ou à 805 855
donc là on est sur un téléviseur oled
qui remplace la gamme 804 de cette année
dans quelle nouveauté qu'est ce qu'on va
porter par rapport à ce qu'on avait
avant alors la nouveauté principale ça
va être la qualité d'image aux élites et
d'image on avait un processeur p 5
on arrive avec nouvelle génération donc
la quatrième génération du processeur p5
qui encore les gradins telli gensac
artificiel c'est la grosse nouveauté
pour l'optimisation vraiment de l'image
exactement reconnaissance de celle je
dirais oui on leur donne de seine et
puis on a une grosse base de données
qu'on a travaillé depuis les 30
dernières années qu'il est noir m
d'analyser les images et de d'équilibré
en fait que ce soit le contraste la
couleur
les mouvements des images et de pouvoir
afficher une image vous aller toujours
plus loin par rapport à ce qu'il a
toujours cherché à améliorer en termes
de gammes de prix sur le lez êtes à
combien
alors aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore les
éléments de prix les produits arriveront
courant du mois de juin
ça marche comment vous situez par
rapport au marché global par rapport à
la concurrence d'une concurrence qui
était féroce vous avez effectivement
cette plus-value vous aujourd'hui qu'est
ambilight qui apporte vraiment les gars
maintenant je le disais tout à l'heure
un peu en plaisantant mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya goûté philips ou un petit
routeur qui permettra d'intégrer
l'embêtant des les bandes l'aide est en
effet en bidaoui sur différentes télé ça
va du coup couper un peu il exclut
ambilight au niveau du téléviseur
alors oui sauf que effectivement pour
avoir une expérience qui est 100%
ambilight et immersion ouais c'est mieux
de l'avoir intégré puisqu'en fait ce
petit routeur il va fonctionner en hdmi
donc avec les sources qui viennent de
l'extérieur
si on regarde un programme du téléviseur
un programme netflix qui est intégré
dans le téléviseur du coup on aura en
face donc pour l'avoir vraiment natif
avec votre android tv et ses intérêts
visage en est exactement l argument de
poids ok ça marche donc comment vous
situez aujourd'hui philippe sur la
partie tv purement et simplement
mais aujourd'hui en fait on est un des
leaders mondial de production de
téléviseurs on est marque très grand
public
on en propose pour tous les goûts du
petit 24 pouces jusqu'aux 75 pouces donc
on a vraiment pour tous les goûts les
usages toutes les bourses
on est une marque hyper fiable qui est
connu du grand public
et puis une des marques préférées des
français il est marié avec de la facture
fait avec un an exactement
moi je l'histoire d'amour c'est vraiment
difficile moi j'ai l'impression que tu
veux qu'en étant petit il y avait
philippe sion au oui mais a continué
aujourd'hui ira du gie et liszt de
génération en génération et de dire ça
mais pas nécessairement en fait tu vas
te dire au niveau de mon téléviseur mais
tu l'as dans beaucoup de produits c'est
la force de la marque dette représente
60 de leur poule ce soit sur la brosse à
dents sur banshee exactement donc
s'envisager dans la salle de bains dans
le vallon on est présent partout
c'est aujourd'hui une des forces de
philips qui fait que les gens viennent
découvrir d'autres produits chimiques où
il reçoit téléviseur pour un choix du
casque pour les choses comme ça mais je
pense que la force de la marque est
vraiment
hyper importante ouais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a connu philips quand
on était petits on reconnaît philips au
fur et à mesure des générations oui j'ai
on est là dans différents produits dont
l'a84 bientôt chez philips alors pour
2021 on y travaille pour l'instant c'est
vrai qu'on a déjà montré des des écrans
mika on y travaille mais on est surtout
en train de voir si le marché presse il
ya du contenu est ce que le marché est
suffisamment mature est ce qu'on arrive
à avoir une offre cohérente sa cause
donc voilà on arrive on c'est important
et ça donc ça va arriver peut-être on
aura une autre information à l'ifa ou
lors latence 2021 je pense qu'on va
attendre plutôt de me paradan 2021 que
livre que vous ne portez pas que la nuit
cas commencent vraiment à se
démocratiser à s'ouvrir davantage et à
ce moment là on pourra voir philippe
merci écoute c'est génial on parlera
nous de fidelio avec les commémorations
avec benoît on va parler fidelio avec
deux mois et on va se s'immerger dans le
côté audio à tuer découvrir un super
produit allégé et des couvertures je
vais tester un petit peu c'est est un
petit peu mais j'ai toujours cru que
curieux d'avoir les retours des
spécialistes à ce sujet
[Musique]
comment ça va écoute très bien voire
très bien tu viens de passer mon
interview cpct pas traumatiser ses coups
de savates
on respire non je comprends le justement
du nouveau fidelio le mx3 fidelio c'est
un produit qui revient fidelio en fait
tu reviens c'est vrai qu'on a eu
quelques petits tumulte récemment et
qu'effectivement au niveau de
l'innovation au niveau des produits on a
eu quelques petits voilà quelques petits
le petit problème
ces deux dernières années et maintenant
on revient en force avec tipis jeunes
qui a donc voilà récupérer la mainmise
sur philips est donc sûre fidelio
fidelio et donc reviendrons un peu en
force avec le x3 qui nous restitue un
petit peu fidelio qu'est ce que ça
raconte comme histoire alors en gros
fidelio c'est si on voit philipps comme
une malle une marque du marché de masse
on a fidelio qui est vraiment le segment
premium de marque là donc c'est vraiment
une approche qui est de avec fidelio qui
est beaucoup plus orienté vers la valeur
du produit que vers vers la quantité et
on est vraiment s'il en fait c'est
vraiment une manière de démontrer ce
qu'on est capable de faire si votre
produit plus abouti le plus haut niveau
a clairement pour le pour les au niveau
des castes c'est vraiment le top déjà
d'une part parce que c'est vrai que vont
dire quelque chose d'assez commun qui
est pour une marque de
deux casques que le vraiment le premium
le top de la gamme soit souvent à un
casque ouvert juste pour situer déjà par
rapport aux prix on n'y a qu'elle prête
le filet 349 349 sans extras donc là on
le voit dit jack double jack jack
symétrique
ça c'est vraiment pour chez soi wes
hanson restent ouvertes ne doit pas
aller dans le métro ou pas leurs
extérieurs pour les audiophiles
exactement c'est un casque et on va dire
linverse de pratique
si tu veux vraiment orienté performances
sonores oriente c'est vraiment
l'archétype du casque pour l'expérience
stéréo et un casque vraiment ouais je me
rends pas compte du marché
là dessus parce que l'audio on nie tout
savoir des écouteurs aujourd'hui il ya
un gros développement au niveau du
sans-fil casque bluetooth qu'on retrouve
beaucoup qui doit permettre d'être si
bien coûter à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur
est-ce que du coup mise à part
effectivement les audiophiles et
extrêmement pointus beaucoup de
consommateurs viennent se positionner
sur des casques ouverts avec des avec
des fils
alors comme je disais c'est vrai que
c'est pas du tout l'archétype du casque
des gens qui cherchent l'aspect pratique
donc effectivement les fonctionnalités
de la gamme x en fait ne sont pas du
tout orienté pratique mais plutôt
expérience sonore expérience design
vraiment on est dans ce domaine là c'est
du premier mais en fait on est vraiment
pour ses leçons avant tout c'est
vraiment l'expérience sonore qui prime
tu te positionnes face a acquis
aujourd'hui la concurrence avec un
produit comme celui là écoute moi
j'aurais envie de dire que s'il y avait
un je ne sais pas s'il y avait vraiment
un casque comme ça que je prendrais
comme comme comme exemple par rapport à
lui je pense que ses nageurs font de
très bons casques le sennheiser hd six
ans doit probablement être une très
bonne référence
et à ce niveau là le x2 x3 se positionne
très bien par rapport à lui je pense que
après on dans ce genre de marché on est
un tout petit peu moins dans des
concurrences claire et et
vraiment c'est expérientiel c'est il
faut que le consommateur puisse le
prendre se poser l'écouté et voir lequel
du correspondant
voilà exactement c'est exactement ça
c'est le principe d'un son qui te
correspond à c'est vraiment comme ça
qu'on le voit quand on monte en gamme
produit tout va bien c'est les codes de
life y avait appliqué au marché de masse
vraiment et donc on n'est plus temps
dans un espace d'une espèce de
concurrence un peu un peu un peu de
front voilà mais plutôt à une volonté de
voilà d'avoir la signature sonore qui
nous plaît et en l'occurrence avec mx 3
c'est un produit qui sortira pas tout de
suite bondissant produit sur joint ouais
on est sûr juin de cette année donc on
est vraiment là on est en sata un pré
production mais on est vraiment vraiment
tout ce qui reste à faire engrosser de
remplacer la main d'oeuvre qui s'occupe
de mettre certaines parties certains
instants certaine partie de l'assemblage
sont toujours faits à la main je suis là
et qui vont être bien sûr industrialisés
réalisé par la suite métier en
l'occurrence on est vraiment sur le même
fort factor sur le même produit sur les
mêmes matériaux rien ne changeait rien
ne changera d'ici où elle joue
exactement c'est certain mais on a nos
partenariats avec les matériaux que ce
soit sur le cuir avec murray doit sur le
sur le tissu avec la droite au québec on
est vraiment sur des matériaux qui ne
peuvent plus changer en à nos
partenariats et on a l'intention des
gardes et non seulement pas seulement
pour le histoire mais alain dans
l'avenir également qu'est ce que ça nous
raconte tout ça c'est donc en tout cas
c'est intéressant philippe c'est qu'en
fait je crois si vous le savez mais en
fait un philips eh bien ils ont délégué
la partie écran la partie télé et la
partie audio atp vision c'est pas un
philips appartient pas à finir sans fins
et ils ont la licence en quelques cents
si vous voulez il utilise la marque
philips mais ce n'est pas philippe
philips existe toujours bel évidemment
elie philips fait plein de choses dans
le domaine médical dans plein de
chevreuse la maison les robots s'annonce
assez plutôt que philips aujourd'hui au
niveau la télé c'est quelque chose comme
10% de part de marché chose qui vraiment
bien honnêtement très très honorable par
rapport à tout ce qu'on peut retrouver à
la concurrence que ce soit des sony dsam
sont en fait ils sont plus intéressés je
dirais pour marcher très grand public
sont pas dans la grosse innovation
ils vont pas arriver en disant ok ok
nous re propose la nuit cas la meilleure
innovation on est bon dans ce qu'on fait
on va pas tout de suite
fer de lance en termes d'innovation on
va pas être tout de suite ceux qui vont
vous proposer et bien géré le truc qui
va être le plus what the fuck la télé
huit cas le grand écran de sang à
quelques pouces c'est pas du tout leurs
approches leur approche et une approche
grand public c'est une approche à un
instant t on dans ok nous on sait faire
ça on le fait on le vend en
commercialise les nous ont montré une
telle et 8 k est ce que maintenant ces
prêts pour la production de masse ça
j'en suis pas vraiment persuadé mais en
tout cas ce qui est intéressant c'est
bien de quelle manière philippe se
positionne par rapport à ces produits
par rapport à ces téléviseurs par
rapport à studio alors les produits je
trouve plutôt cool sur le principe j'ai
déjà testé de la télé ambilight ça
marche bien l'effet est toujours là
après au delà de ça si y'avait pas cet
effort be like parce que c'est quelque
chose qui marcherait autant moi c'est
vraiment ils atteignent aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment ce qui fait vraiment la
valeur ajoutée la partie audio je sais
pas je ne sens pas tout de suite bien
dans l'histoire forcément bien convaincu
il faudrait du temps pour tester ce
nouveau casque fidelio le x3 voir si la
qualité est vraiment au rendez vous
j'arrive pas à me rendre compte je sais
pas ben voilà allez on se pose dans le
hilton c'est l'instant de partir dans
tera des relais pas mal là voilà on part
tout à leur direction de thalys à jour
mais bonjour monsieur vous étiez ici
mais vous êtes c'est ont croisé est ce
qu'on sait crois que vous êtes tous
c'est quoi tes pas venu à la soirée hier
torride et tu vois je sens que ça te
manque le fait de chutes ont remis en
fin de compte c'était bien on s'est bien
marré quand même carrément donc c'était
cool plus en plus et on n'a pas quitté
l'hôtel presque pas on est resté à
l'hôtel
ici on en est resté là dans cet hôtel
largement au dessus de nos moyens c'est
bien on a invité donc oui c'est tout
mais c'est rap c'est très bien parce
qu'on peut faire des choses
intéressantes et voir des produits et
des gens absolument mais c'était cool
quoi voilà donc je ne sais pas ce que tu
voulais dire toi aussi tu attends comme
ça c'est sa chaîne à derna pas commencer
à [ __ ] la merde chez les hommes je
veux pas qu'on le change le nom de
[ __ ] la merde formation ma chaîne va
verser bon dieu c'était très cool
j'espère que ça vous aura intéressé
marque moi tout ça en commentaire et
puis on se retrouve demain pour tu vas
parler de take-two retrouveront pp je
supporte a des cheveux comme mec quand
même s'ils ont globalement par rapport à
moi ça tirait bien comme ça non je dois
je suis pas très sympa très cheveux
comme mec c'est quoi c'est plus à la
mode les chaussées passé d'homme et
c'est totalement mais has been avoir
droit de la touffeur c'est fini que j'ai
à dire les cas fait une bouffe beaucoup
de tours 2 à 2 millimètres a plus de
problème de pellicule t'as plus rien et
puis des trucs importants qu'en tapage
que je le donne à chacun un truc
important tu te réveilles que la même
tête que tu te couches tu plonges du
ressort de loot à la même tête la même
tête tout le temps il n'y a pas de
surprise
tu ne concerne pas les cernes quand même
temps les services je dis je je je dors
dans le formol je n'ai pas de sens d un
homme
c'est ça ton secret c'est leur fouras je
vous le laisse
parce que si ça d'une rare insignifiant
je peux moi aussi je pense je m'arrête
là
[Musique]